hi I'm Erik Bosse an Avengers board just
revealed that actress Catherine Langford
will appear in an unknown role and the
identity of her character could have
some major implications on how the
Avengers could defeat Thanos and what
kind of movies the MCU could do in phase
four and now I have added Langford show
13 reasons why does shows that I have to
watch a preparation for ventures for
apparently 13 reasons why my work-life
balance is gone I'm gonna break this all
down and toiler already in case I am too
right okay so the most widespread theory
is that Catherine Lankford will be
playing Kate Bishop Kate Bishop is a
legacy character who takes on the hawk I
named after Clint Barton she's a member
of the Young Avengers and she teams up
with Hawkeye and Matt Fraction at
davidow has excellent recent Hawkeye
Series Clinton kata a combated
mentor-student relationship and through
Kate Bishop we really learned what makes
Hawkeye unique valuable contribution in
the Marvel world because really smaller
solo missions are aware expert archers
can really shine even Hawkeye knows this
city's flying we're fighting an army of
robots and I have a bow and arrow none
of this makes sense fest Hawkeye line
ever if link were displaying Kate Bishop
that could hint at the mystery around
Hawkeye for Avengers infinity war in
Avengers 4 where the hell is Hawkeye Ben
we're dying to know well honestly it's
more like number 40 on the list of
questions between Ovidius infinity war
in of interest for but an infinity war
you may remember Black Widow confirm
that Clint was on house arrest with his
family which is not an interesting
enough answer especially since we saw
how easy it was for a doofus like Scott
Lang to slip his security detail in
ant-man when wasp so I see two options
here with Keith Bishop
option 1 maybe Clint Barton did
legitimately sit out the events of
infinity war in his farmhouse deciding
that protecting his wife and three kids
and his stupid barn were more important
than helping his friend saved the entire
world but then Diana says snap hits and
some or maybe all of his family members
dust away he loses it he walks the earth
for a few years starts listening to
Evanescence and these zips arrows into
anything
that reminds him of dust basically a lot
of chalkboards and like dryer lint traps
then we pick back up with him in
Avengers four and Clinton meets the only
person on earth as good as he is with a
bow and arrow maybe even better
Kate Bishop and Siri awakens his
fighting spirit with an opportunity to
build something new out of the ashes but
the other way I see this going option
two maybe we had it wrong with our
assumptions that Hawkeye even survived
the snap now sure Kevin Feige has said
that you can do the math at leaving the
original six Avengers left alive was an
intended part of the design of
vendedores
ending but so far the main evidence that
we have that Hawkeye survived our leak
set photos proving that Jeremy Renner
shot scenes for Avengers four and with
all my recent speculation that Avengers
4 could explore alternate parallel
realities and dimensions that might not
even be the Hawkeye from this reality so
what if Hawk I did actually dust away
and a new vigilante who really looked up
to him maybe someone he was training at
the time takes over in his absence kate
bishop and then maybe an Avengers
forward they do go this way and they
start meddling with quantum mechanics
and the avengers visit a parallel
reality where hawkeye is still alive
that could explain their intercept photo
now I should say that it has not been
completely confirmed that Kathryn
Langford will even be playing Kate
Bishop I think fans just kind of jumped
to that conclusion because Kate is a
shortened version of the name Kathryn
and both have long dark hair what you
know is really all proved I need but I
still think it's worth exploring some
other options of who she could be
playing one rumors suggested that she
could be playing the daughter of Tony
Stark and Pepper Potts remember in the
movie they floated the name Morgan
assuming that Avengers Ford does take
place after a significant time jump from
infinity Wars oh so there's various
cosmic characters that play major roles
in the Infinity Gauntlet comics that
Langford could be playing mistress death
is one death is the love interest of
Thanos the figure he does all of his
universe halves the rapturing for know
the infinity war movie characterized
Thanos is more of an eco-terrorist and
ideologues see himself as a good guy and
they kind of do away with the whole
death character though visually they do
kind of reference the character of mr.
stress with the Red Skull cameo there's
also the cosmic entity of the Living
Tribunal who plays a major role in
Infinity Gauntlet as the universal judge
that they appeal to and they try to get
the little
you know to intervene and stop Thanos
but ultimately lived in tribunal rules
and Thanos his favor I gotta say link
words a young actress she's 22 years old
and unless they're planning on doing
some interesting take on the Libyan
tribunal I would say Langford skill set
as a performer could be better used them
as a cosmic judge the other theory that
I find interesting is that lengths bird
could be playing Thanos his mother the
eternal sweet son perhaps in a flashback
showing Thanos his birth in Thanos's
back story in the comics when Thanos was
born they realized that he carried the
deviant gene resulting in his different
appearance ants we saw and tried to kill
the child
fearing the deadly future this demon
baby could bring about but she was
stopped by Thanos his father
Lars Lars was actually named dropped in
Infinity Ward by Red Skull who greeted
Thanos on premiere as son of Ella's that
could be a hint that part two of the
story would explore more of theosis
origin and perhaps his mother there have
been a few other names mentioned for who
Langford could be playing the Marvel
Universe is filled with young women but
I'm thinking she will end up playing one
of these more well-known characters or
maybe just a new role created specific
for the story of adventure sport and
none of us will really be talking about
after the movie but I still want to know
from you guys what new character do you
want to see introduced in Avengers 4 I
know it's already pretty crowded
especially with Captain Marvel joining
the mix as well but there is plenty of
room back doored a new face in this
movie as it pivots the MCU into phase 4
so comment down below with your thoughts
and follow new rock stars on twitter and
instagram at new rockstars and for my
terrifying inner thoughts follow me on
twitter and institution Finity fan guys
we sold out last month and we're back
for a new show with some new material
new cast members and some extra costume
padding because it turns out I do not
fill out a form fitting spider-man
unitard as well as I thought of it it's
Friday November 16th 8 p.m. acne theater
North Hollywood ticket info will be
available soon and subscribe to this
channel for more Avengers updates and to
see me gradually wither away in the dust
as the list of shows and movies that I
have to watch consumes me
Oh mr. Molina I don't feel so good